all right so if you play league you'll
know the friendly tree man Ivan for most
of his six year long history he's been a
pretty Niche pick but recently a lot of
content creators have been like this
about him Riot way over above Ivan for
this patch that's not fair they broke
him they overtuned him I burned 53.36
win rate the rank 1 jungler the new Ivan
is
I'm not gonna lie I've been absolutely
abusing
using it recently he's been my main for
years now so let's talk about how
exactly Riot broke him and whether the
recent nurse to him are enough to kill
the monster they've created
[Music]
before we get into it I want to let you
know we've just released a video
covering all of the hype from this
year's Snapdragon mobile Masters thanks
to our friends over at Snapdragon Elite
Gaming for bringing us all the way to
Japan to experience this incredible
tournament where we witnessed one of the
greatest Underdog runs in Brawl Stars
history check out the video in the link
below alright so I have been a fan of
Ivan for years now I even have a custom
made picture of him framed on my wall
right there yeah I know that's some some
real nerdy right there I always found
him unique and fun to play but it's been
quite a while since I've been able to
call him strong until this month because
this month Ivan's been busted out of the
46 junglers on op.gg he's had an
eye-watering 53.41 win rate second among
all junglers now if you've been away
from the game for a while you might find
that quite surprising to see most other
popular and strong junglers right now
are hard-hitting assassins and fight
pointers like kha'zix rexai Kindred
Rengar Champions that will famously your
shut up in comparison Ivan is a support
champion at heart he can root enemies
and knock them up with his ultimate
Daisy while shielding his allies and
creating brushes for them his whole kit
is designed to empower his team but
never to be the one who actually won the
nines games himself but that is exactly
what's been happening this month so what
changed well in patch 13.10 Ivan was
lingering among the worst junglers in
the entire game sitting at a 49 win rate
with a less than one percent pick rate
he was extremely down bad after the item
rework and durability changes and he
looks set for another slap in the face
when Ryan introduced buff sharing for
all Champions the ability to create a
second blue or red buff for an ally has
historically been a unique mechanic of
Ivans it was never a game changer but it
definitely made him a more appealing
teammate because of it and so to
compensate for this loss of exclusivity
on Ivan and the fact that they delayed
his planned mid-scope rework Riot buffed
his kids across the board in patch 1311.
his Q made it easier to choose between
following it into melee or range
distance and its cooldown was reduced by
50 when used on non-epic Monsters his
brushes were changed to last longer and
also buff allies or to attacks his
Shield's duration is now renewed if it
isn't broken or doesn't damage an enemy
and his ultimate Daisy got a slew of
Buffs to her including increased attack
range movement speed and attack speed is
the attack range 125 you want 75k Daisy
age period
Italy
finally bro holy
now these Buffs were strong by
themselves but it was their Synergy with
items and runes that really pushed Ivan
into full-blown Brokenness because one
thing that wasn't really mentioned in
the patch notes is that Daisy now
applies on hit effects so people quickly
started running press the attack Nash's
tooth rhinelized crystal scepter because
all of their on-hit effects are now
granted to Daisy as well this turned her
into essentially a sixth teammate not
only is she faster and stronger thanks
to the Buffs but her ability to utilize
on her effects means the enemies can't
ignore her and even if they do try and
fight her she'll still probably just
them up it's a lose-lose situation
for the enemy Team all of this while
Ivan just sits back and continuously
Shields Daisy for days on end and if the
enemy does get wise and decides to focus
Ivan instead he just Shields himself
hits him with a Q and pieces out this
incredibly safe yet oppressive gameplay
has even opened up new role
opportunities for Ivan in the past you
were basically trolling if you played
him outside of jungle or support and
even support was questionable but with
these Buffs he quickly became viable in
mid and top where he can go toe-to-toe
with a lot of Champions pre-level six
and then just bully them out of Lane
with the help of Daisy I've even seen
people pulling him off as an ad carry I
repeat Ivan A.D Carrie this is not a
drill now despite how absolutely broken
all of this is he's still not been
picked or banned as much as you'd expect
of a champion with his win rate why is
this well even though Ivan has been
really strong this month he's still Ivan
and I'll be the first to admit he does
have a very unique style of gameplay
those who find him fun like me love that
about him I love microing Daisy using
her as a sort of Shield bomb delivery
system and positioning her for the
perfect knock-up I love his unique
farming system which allows for
interesting jungle pathing and cheeky
invades but some people find all that
just too different to the Champions that
they're used to and may even find Ivan
boring as a result now personally I
think that shows a bit of a lack of
imagination but obviously I'm quite
biased myself a lot of people including
Ivan Maines like myself were expecting
the nurse to come at some point and come
they they did with yesterday's release a
patch 1313. the bonus on hit damage from
his brushes took a hit as well as
Daisy's movement speed and base damage
now on the surface I don't really think
these Nerfs are too devastating they'll
definitely take him down a peg but I
don't see any nerve to those absolutely
overpowered on hit effects we talked
about earlier I jumped into the practice
tour today and Daisy still procs Nash's
tooth and pressed the attack which is a
sizable reason as to why people felt
Ivan has been so strong recently and not
to mention there's been no nerves to his
jungle clearing I don't think many
people realize that Ivan can do a one
Smite level 4 full first clear before
three minutes these nerves obviously
don't affect that I still think Ivan is
going to be decently strong this patch I
think Riot are hesitant to Nerf him into
the ground because they feel bad that
their mid-scope rework for him has been
delayed so Ivan players have a little
bit more time perhaps to take advantage
of Riot's Guild and by Ivan players I
mean me obviously me definitely me I'll
see whether or not these nerves have
successfully killed the monster and I'll
see you all in the next one
of our co-workers who will not be named
joke that the reason people aren't
playing Ivan is because he's boring so
people play like two games with him and
they go what the hell's this I don't
know what's going on he's boring it's
like nah you get out of Ivan what you
put into Ivan you put two games in
you're not gonna get anything out of him
you put two years in and it starts to
get fun